hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
and unless there's been a coup I'm Dave
Reuben I've got Liane tweetIn and Jena
grad with me let's get to it
all right George Bush george w bush he's
back people he was interviewed by ABC's
Jonathan Karl and he's chiming in or not
so chiming in kinda on some stuff let's
take a look at the first clip I saw a
journalist in Zambia asked you about gay
marriage and whether it is compatible
with Christian values and you had an
interesting response I shouldn't be
taking a speck I meant that I wasn't
gonna answer the question then and I'm
not going to answer it now in terms of
the political question about whether or
not you know I just don't want to wade
back in the debate I'm out of politics
but I met it's very important for people
not to be overly critical as someone
else until you've examined your own
heart all right I like that quote I want
to get it right I shouldn't be taking a
speck out of someone else's eye when I
have a log in my own is that a subtle
gay joke I'm not so sure lady what do
you think about this because it seems to
me that you know he gets out and now
he's starting to chime back in on things
but still just won't jump on the game
man I mean just go for it already I
think you know I totally respect his
view of not responding he isn't the
president anymore and I'm sure they
asked him for the interview and they
want to ask him about that because it's
his party and what does he think I'm
okay with that and I think that the end
that last quote he was probably
referring to Dick Cheney who has a gay
daughter and you know so I'm saying I
think he's going look most Americans are
very personal in their politics and you
go and you you vote your politics when
you go to the voting booth and a lot of
times you don't know what your neighbor
thinks or what they're gonna vote on so
I think he's like you know what to each
his own and I'm out of politics I don't
need to answer that question and I
respect that a defense of George Bush in
the Young Turks to do how about that do
you think the president what to do you
mean do you think the former presidents
that they should just stay out of every
well I I don't think they should stay
out if they have an opinion go for it
but I think we're all so used to it's
been long enough that w hasn't been in
the office that we're used to him saying
something stupid there our coffee table
books about it there's all kinds of you
know funny little things and memes and
all the stuff that everything that comes
out of his mouth is complete chaos and
crazy [ __ ] it is so refreshing for
him to be like look I'm out of politics
and to each his own and all these
wonderful things that we could have used
you know very quiet
he's been very quiet in his retirement
which has been great he's like you know
what I'm out I don't I don't need to to
talk about things yeah and he doesn't
want to get exactly thrown back into
this was there a little piece of it
that's a little disingenuous you know it
was him when he was being reelected that
made gay marriage like a real wedge
issue talk about it now I mean why are
you why are you if he wants to keep it
personal why are you mad that he doesn't
want to say it out loud I don't know
that a man it just seems to me like get
on the right side you know if he
supported gay marriage I'd be even more
pissed cuz I'd be like where was this
guy made a difference right now all of a
sudden it's okay for you know screw you
well that's an interesting point because
somebody like Dick Cheney the second he
was out suddenly oh now he backs gay
marriage everybody everybody the second
they're not in it anymore
how about our Vice President now he's
probably written a few chapters you get
this like crazy old uncle George vibe
and it's like you know he's he's an old
he's elderly now kind of he just go sit
in the corner he comes up as more
likeable now for sure but let's let's
watch this other clip so he was also
discussing the NSA tactics and what
happens once you become president and he
was sort of backing President Obama on
this take listen are you surprised the
President Obama's kept in place so many
of your counterterrorism programs
including was he criticized as a
candidate
I think the president got into the Oval
Office and realized the dangers to the
United States and he's acted in a way
that he thinks is necessary to protect
the country protecting the country is
the most important job of the presidency
okay so I can kind of back what the
ladies are saying about the gay marriage
thing and he's trying not to jump in on
it this thing though seems really awful
to me because everyone runs on an idea
and then the second they become
president they change everything below
now I have some new information and now
I have to say some other things is it
why do we believe anyone that's running
for anything ever right if you look at
Obama's track record on everything that
he promised when he became president I
think he's done like maybe a half of one
thing so he's been very terrible on that
record if you look at the facts whether
I'm an Obama supporter or not I'm not
gonna say that but I'm just saying if
you look at the facts what he said so
right so even though hey stuff for
example he said or we're gonna do this
responsibly a lot of things continued on
the wars okay I think he realizes things
aren't shutting down Guantanamo things
aren't as easy as what they say and the
platform that everybody wants to hear
let's let's let's submit it politicians
say what you want to hear so people go
oh yeah we're robbed and a vote for that
and then nothing happens but I think
when it comes to NSA look we all know
we've been surveilling each other it's
been happening I mean the Cold War
people just said yesterday oh you know
what there's still some towers up that
the Russians have you know why
everybody's spying on each other
everybody has technology everybody knows
you sure has it gone too far maybe in
you know saying it's the defense of the
country sure it probably has stopped a
lot of things so there is a fine line I
don't know I'm not president I know it's
a really damn difficult job but is that
is that a valid excuse because they all
run the saying one thing and then the
excuse just come I mean even Bill Maher
was giving Obama a pass on this saying
well you find out stuff you know the
same thing that Bush said I was hoping
for like more of like a hot chick like
point counterpoint but I agree at the
end because that's exactly I think when
when you're running and you haven't been
in the president before you are the
people's voice and then once you cross
that line you're the president now it's
kind of you against them because you
know things they will
for now don't want that list like is
isn't that why their hair turns gray
after like two weeks because they're
told like you know age right here the
lizard people are among us and they're
like oh everything that we don't know so
all of a sudden they're not speaking for
us anymore right so we're all admitting
freely that when they're speaking for us
before they become president that it's
all a lie right I mean is that pretty
much what we're saying that it's sort of
willful ignorance just politics money
lobbyists there's a lot of things that
come about when you actually get into
the office and then you go well I would
like to pass this but then I'm not going
to get this this and this done or pushed
through if I don't get them to work with
me so it's a lot more difficult
look all politicians across the board
are liars and they know they say things
that they will never be able to fulfill
and democracy yeah so final point on
this should obey uh actually be a little
annoyed at george w bush because when he
says nice things about him that can't be
good for Obama's ratings or should be
like I'll take it I have a quick
anecdotal support of what you just said
I just live in a super bad neighborhood
if for a long time and every a couple
nights a week a cop would roll up next
to me be like hey do you want me to you
know escort you home and it's like get
the [ __ ] out of yeah like I'm ruining my
reputation of them in Africa like their
buddies Obama's like let's move on let's
talk about Obama's official network
MSNBC they just loved him over there and
actually a former employee of MSNBC a
producer on Donahue do you remember Phil
Donahue had a show on MSNBC his show
actually got canceled literally on the
eve of the Iraq war because he was
against the Iraq war so that shows you
how times change but his producer Jeff
Cohen
wrote a blistering open letter about
what MSNBC has become and I thought it
was pretty interesting let's take a read
when it comes to issues of u.s.
militarism and spying the alleged
progressive MSNBC seems closer to the
official network of the Obama White
House than anything resembling an
independent channel with a few
exceptions especially Chris Hayes MSNBC
has usually reacted to expanded
militarism and surveillance by
downplaying the abuses or defending them
had McCain or Romney defeated Obama and
implemented the exact same policies
treating whistleblowers like Manning and
Snowden as foreign espionage agents one
would expect MSNBC hosts to be loudly
denouncing the Republican abuses of
authority but with Obama in power a
number of MSNBC Talking Heads have
reacted to the Snowden disclosures like
Fox News host did when they were in
hysterical damage control mode for Bush
complete with ridiculously fact-free
claims and national chauvinism that
we've long come to expect from the fair
and balance Channel I mean that is a
pretty scathing attack from a former
employee not just an employee a producer
of a primetime show on the network and I
pretty much agree with everything that
he said their MSNBC has become as bad to
the left as Fox News is to the right
we've talked about this a bunch on this
show are they just the official network
of the administration pretty much I
don't think that's it's like nobody
doesn't know that unless you're living
under a rock and then Fox is the same
way to the right I think any news
channel in America is biased they're all
skewed one way or another that I think
there's a lot more left
you know leanin news organizations so
that's why I always like to watch BBC I
like to watch foreigner even Al Jazeera
has some some some stories that you can
read that aren't so biased to party
sides you know and going down lines and
just oh giving blind passes to whatever
you know whoever they agree with oh yeah
sure of course but then it Bush did it
it would be like the end of the world
well so I don't put much he's surprised
I mean he went to work at this you know
he produced at this network did he not
know what MSNBC was before you and well
they were that bad with
was doing this that's true you know 12
years ago you're exactly right do you
think this is worse because when it's on
the side of power then it's actually
worse you know do you mean like Fox News
is going against the power now not that
I'm defending Fox News but and everybody
wants to take down you know whoever has
the most power but that's the thing I'm
wondering the same thing who didn't know
this why is this an issue like I mean
this is brought to you from the
Institute of no [ __ ] oh we all know this
this is not breaking new I mean yes
MSNBC is more liberal
yes Fox is more conservative what what
am I missing something this article five
times and I was like I want to see The
Crying Game it was like there's a secret
there's a secret I'm like okay
the credits are rolling I must have
missed this does this have something to
do with the chick with the penis because
I knew that from the beginning what am I
missing in this article yeah you think
it's even more obvious like wait a
minute okay so do you think that
articles like this cuz this stuff is now
being written all the time like it used
to be everything was against Fox one way
but this kind of stuff is popping up now
is this just because we get such
tailored news because we're all getting
news from Twitter so you pick the people
you like you follow news that just
reinforces everything you believe that
you like I mean you're not gonna watch
Game of Thrones if you don't like that
kind of storyline I mean you know
anything you're gonna watch Breaking Bad
or whatever so people choose what they
sure it's kind of the same beliefs it's
the same you know it's like going to
church you go to the Church of the
belief that you follow because you're
like yeah that's what I believe in so
that's what I'm gonna go with I mean you
know it's like I said but it's so biased
and skewed and I think it didn't help
that this administration's spokesman has
been very aloof and a lot of things
doesn't like to answer a lot of things
and MSNBC has been very supportive of
that and not really questioning them and
not really making it you know when he's
turning down people that have been in
the press corps for twenty years and not
answering questions and being
transparent like the government said
they would be it's you know it gets very
frustrating so when other liberal
networks are actually calling them the
official network of the Obama White
House then then then you have to go home
something might be wrong here is that
the bigger problem that we I think
people that are on the left or that are
progressive we expect the left to be a
little
yeah we expect them deal the police
themselves and they just simply can yeah
I can control it's like a locomotive
that's kind of gotten if they forgot
like where are the brakes and gone
everybody wants to think that the side
that they that they align with is the
one that that is the most balanced that
is not just telling people what they
want to hear and I think that we all
have to kind of wake up to that because
my own my presets on my radio in my car
are super super conservative radio and
public radio and I just back and forth
back and forth depending on when certain
people are on so I do something similar
to on Twitter I actually follow a lot of
people that I don't like just so I can
chime in and get something whatever just
to get a thank you I mean I like that
you know I I lean more conservative I'm
more liberal or libertarian than
anything you know so I'm just like kind
of government stay out of my way I'm not
crazy religious or anything I'm just a
fiscally conservative and money and
thing policy and things like that but
it's like I'm liberal and all my other
things gay marriage great you know
abortion you know it's not my cup of tea
but I'm not gonna stop anybody from
doing their own thing you know what I
mean so I kind of fit into the middle of
these two worlds which is bizarre so I
kind of have to look at both sides and I
think that makes people well-rounded
yeah well actually this is a total
sidebar to this but today is Elisabeth
Hasselbeck last day on the view and
she's now moving so she's moving at Fox
and Friends no surprise to anyone but I
think you're hitting on something that's
really interesting is that she was
really I guess too conservative somehow
for ABC which is bizarre because I think
she actually for 10 years I think that
was like a good run and she also did an
incredible job I mean she was dealing
with Joy Behar and Rosie O'Donnell and
like so on and there's some of the best
seasoned comics that we have on on the
left and female klava but is there
something dangerous about someone like
her a pretty rat I think a pretty how
can I say this without everyone is
attacking me a pretty same conservative
or socially liberal but fiscally
conservative if someone like that can't
exist on the networks that's an even
bigger problem don't you think yeah and
when you said rat I was hoping you were
to say radical but you're all different
yes but I agree it's like 10 years who
gets to do that I mean I think that was
a success as far as agencies concerned
so I'm not unless they're spinning it
that way cuz it's our great she's living
in DC wouldn't have kept her on for ten
years if they if she did not pull
ratings yeah I mean let's face it they
have and then having her it was almost
like oh well throw the little right-wing
conservative girl in the corner and see
how she fares against all these
Rottweilers and pit bulls and she did
for ten years you know and I think that
you've networks they're all about money
and they're all about ratings and
they're all about advertising and if she
wasn't pulling in any of those as part
of that group she would have gone a long
time ago and I'm I'm from Kansas I'm
from the Midwest
and you know they're always looking for
someone to represent the great unwashed
as they used to be called the flyover
State of America right because
apparently we're all the same Jew from
Kansas by the way so we're not all the
same
um but I think that she was she was the
representative of all of the flyover
States and everyone else just got to
just do their things yeah all right I
did not know there
I did not know there were any all right
well going from what they call fair and
balanced to completely unbalanced well
you know what watch yourself here's Pat
Robertson when we like things on
Facebook if it's something that goes
against what is written in the Bible
such as pictures of same-sex couples is
that considered condoning the behavior
how do you explain this to new
Christians or youth well I'm not one who
switches on likes and Facebook so it's
hard to say but what you're saying is
yes I like this kind of thing you've got
a couple of same-sex guys kissing you
like that well that makes me want to
throw up but if you think a you punch it
to me I would punch vomit not black but
anyhow you can donate yes you can don't
you okay do you guys have that searing
pain going through your brain how this
man is
even allowed he's alive that I guess he
funds his own network or the people that
are giving money to Jesus they're
putting up his television program anyway
he's punching vomit and can I just do a
quick roll yeah when I believe when
somebody says I don't push likes on
Facebook that is you're gonna say about
it
but the more offensive part like his
just language around faith punching the
the like button that's really I respect
his beliefs and he has every right to
believe what he wants to believe that's
that's his right and I think it's I
probably never would have seen that clip
and less Steve you sent it to us I am
not I'm sorry so I did not get that clip
in my weekly email but um you know take
it for what it's worth I think people
are gonna look at that clip and people
make their own decisions and be like
okay he's just like he's like crazy old
man right that has no that just can't
see the world like that people are
different and they whatever you know and
vomit okay whatever so there's actually
a my part of the problem here because
we're talking about this and it seems to
me that more people talk about Pat
Robertson the natural I don't know
anyone that watches the show but every
time he says something stupid it's on
every website I think it's actually good
to talk about because I think it's a
gauge of where the super super crazy
hardcore conservatives are even if
they're 140 because we've been seeing I
think what I've noticed is a lot of
really really conservative people
breaking down a little bit and and
accepting that the world is changing and
people are evolving and maybe what they
thought was true is not and so this is a
good temperature gauge of okay here's
another one
is he is he breaking down to see that
you know people are people know right
uncle Pat just go yet sit in the corner
you know this is Pat Roberts who of
course always blames gay people for
hurricanes and all that stuff he just a
few weeks ago he said that you know
someone called in and said that their
wife had Alzheimer's and he said well
you're allowed to cheat on her now I
mean he's pretty intellectually
inconsistent with all that stuff so
which makes the point I think why does
God have such bad mess
you know you mean God every time I think
of someone screaming about God it's
either Pat Robertson or you know Rick
Santorum or some idiot on the subway in
New York City screaming about Jesus why
doesn't be a better message I'm supposed
to answer a question with a question but
do you really believe that these people
are the messengers of God I'm not sure
they count right so you want a
card-carrying yeah why doesn't if
religion is a legitimate thing and and
all that if we're gonna go that route
for a set for the purposes of the
conversation I mean why doesn't God or
whoever have better representative
better preaching more of the peace type
things and except your neighbor and all
that I've said this my whole life I
think religion is a personal thing and
I'd like to keep it personal you know I
don't it's hard for me to get behind
somebody like him who says sort of crazy
things and I think a lot of people
probably even conservatives can say okay
that's a little crazy that's a little
much like my my my wife has Alzheimer's
so you're allowed you have a pass you
can go cheat on her I'm like when is
that ever okay on even people that are
atheist what in the Bible did Gabe you
know gave him that when they when they
try to say things that the Bible didn't
actually quite say but they're
interpreting I'm like okay wait so
you're a man that's interpreting
something that I'm just supposed to
blindly follow when maybe if I read it I
would interpret it another way and a
great example that I'm not a New
Testament scholar by any stretch the
imagination or old testament when they
say that really because we brought you
on that they mentioned not not to eat
shrimp you know a thousand more times
then man not to lay with a man so you
know it's maybe lay off the crustaceans
too while you're preaching at about
right you know and doesn't it say really
that a man shall not lay with a man as
he would a woman but most gay men don't
lay with women like that so it's really
not alright well moving from one crazy
TV idea to another DirecTV is launching
dog TV yeah that's a television channel
for your dog so that you know people
leave the radio on when they go out or
they leave the TV on for their dog but
now it is 24-hour programming for
your dog and we've got a little sneak
peek of it
okay so that clip obviously is mainly
for Buddhist dogs yeah I like how it was
all dogs and then suddenly a stingray
got in there I don't know how that
happened
so yeah this is you know dogs like to
watch stingrays oh my god did you know
that so yes this is an actual television
channel that will be for dogs I don't
know how they're going to get people to
advertise on it but that's a whole other
situation minute is this completely
crazy I know we have this thing as as
humans but I think it's particularly
with Americans that we love to put human
emotions on our dogs and we think that
they're thinking the same things we're
thinking about but they're animals
aren't they do they need TV shows
I wouldn't put this on for my fictitious
dog but I would watch it 24 it was very
much like you said like the DAO of dog
it's kind of like that you know the
whole vibe but I think it's so stupid
but it's for people who put their and no
offense I don't know if this was
includes either you but people who put
their dogs in like buggy who say like
what about these people that walk their
cats have you ever seen them I got a guy
that lives near me right now that see
walking Mike oh you walk your cat I
don't actually walk him but one of them
he's he's an indoor cat but he can scale
a six and a half foot wall and I don't
want him to get out of the yard so I
have him in a harness if he wants to go
outside or other cat just goes outside
he you know eat some grass right with
gold but I would never I would never
take him out front like walking down
Melrose because it's impossible I tried
it really is this just like someone
network executive came up with this idea
and DirecTV said let's do the dog
because I know said executive at DIRECTV
and I need to put a phone call in to I'm
not gonna name any names uh I think
they're trying to go on and look the
animals and pets are a billion dollar
industry even just in America one so we
all like to put our dogs and carriers
get their nails painted by them crazy
things that they probably don't need if
right exactly little barrettes and stuff
but don't we understand that dogs a are
pretty much color blind B they're all
sensory based I'm sure they can sort of
see the TV I played little videos of
like dogs barking to see if my dog cut
she gets up she looks at the screen and
then like after a few seconds she's she
goes and lays back down so it's like
they can't smell them they can't touch
them they can't feel them so I'm like
what's the point I'm gonna pay five nine
you know $4.99 five bucks six bucks or
whatever a month for this I don't think
it's gonna go and I really you know how
do we know the dog just put on the
television the dogs can watch whatever
is on TV isn't this a little bit like
you guys remember baby Mozart that was
really hot for like a couple years and
they said well if you play Mozart for
the babies it's gonna make their brains
do other and then and you have something
brewing in that belly some classical
music sometimes we go to bed but I
haven't done any of the baby money and
you can't you can't feel the baby going
to I like that Beethoven they say that
if you play it before and then you play
it when they're born they sort of stop
and I'm like really
throw some papers out maybe like look
what I can pose right he'll be a
tortured artist that's what it'll be
like Moe type I wonder if because like
you said it is a huge industry people
treat their pets like they're their
children and I know and we all you know
everybody does and and babysitters when
I was growing up was Disney Channel
Nickelodeon HBO and they're like well
hey if it worked for me and I turned out
okay I was like you had to wait for you
damn cartoons for three hours on
Saturday morning that's what you had
that's before cable getting up they were
they were on at like 7:00 in the morning
right but that's not saying they were
only on for a few hours you only got
cartoons like oh yeah yeah right would
you would you five dollars a month would
you get in on this I mean my dog I look
I have a television and I have a dog
they've never seen my dog pay any
attention to the television and dogs
bark on TV sometimes and she does she's
not an idiot she knows they can't touch
them it's not it's not three-dimensional
it's like what's the point you're harder
than that and as you said they are color
blind you know they don't have rods and
cones so that changes their their visual
perception you know remember that
episode of The Simpsons where they they
do it out of the dogs out of Santa's
little helpers eyes so you can see what
he's seeing and it's all this mumbled
and the audio and it and it worries me
because people already are you know a
lot of people are lazy with their dogs
and I think I'll just put the TV on I'll
come back on Tuesday yeah put on TV or
the radio when they leave the house
anyways for their pets yeah okay great
yeah all right well from doggy porn the
to regular porn we're go we're jumping
back when we're gonna talk well you know
what watch the clip and then we'll go
ladies there is a crisis looming in the
church it has been called the new
bubonic plague as addictive as crack
cocaine Satan is silently attacking the
minds of Christian men with a weapon
which threatens husbands dads fiance's
and even church leaders that weapon is
pornography pornography pornography
pornography pornography pornography
pornography pornography pornography worn
pornography pornography is easily
available affordable much of it is free
anonymous nobody has to know there's
almost a 100 percent chance that your
son will be exposed to some type of
pornography their cell phone can be a
tool used by Satan to gain a stronghold
into your child's mind I believe as many
as 80% of men in the church are
struggling with some level of viewing
pornography 40% of those responding
struggle with pornography 30% of pastors
had nude pornography as a pastor I have
seen firsthand pornography's devastating
effects on a man his marriage his home
his job and his
leadership within the church the concept
I want you to take out of this video is
what happens to you when you get into
porn zone once the climax is over
through masturbation are through acting
out sexually in other ways a man returns
to his senses if you will then he will
think what was I thinking why did I
throw away everything that is dear to me
for this if there is any pornography in
your home destroy it immediately you
need to destroy all your porn stash --is
you may even need to destroy your
present computer that leaves no place
for forming
pornography I don't think I got the
point of that it was pornography I'm
literally speechless I've watched that
ten times and it gets crazier each time
first off I'm pretty sure it was an
advertisement before night it's free
it's anonymous okay all right I mean he
threw out some crazy at 80% of men are
struggling with porn 30% of pastors or
watching porn I think it's just 80% of
dudes watch much porn okay so there's a
lot of different ways we can go with
this and I'm even gonna take the high
road and not even comment on that man's
precisely Ellen's cousin perhaps or
maybe he's gay let's alright but let's
take the high road and leave that aside
what I mean what do people fear about
porn what is it about watching porn that
people think it's going to destroy the
world to me I think it's religious
though it's only the religious people
that have a problem with it but I think
when you look at a little bit you look
at the Catholic Church for example they
have a huge problem with priests
molesting young boys hey I think because
the problem is they haven't really
gotten with the 21st century and you
realize oh maybe a man and a woman
should be allowed to be married right so
maybe they wouldn't just be segregated
their whole lives and sexually
suppressed and think that the only warm
thing I'm gonna get is an altar boy at
the same time they tell you being gay is
bad so if you don't have to get married
it's a pretty great place to go if you
don't want to be with a woman and that's
right so you know and any look it really
I mean where is this guy living because
porn is not just porn where you find it
on redtube for free on the internet
we're talking about you can watch a
twelve-year-old girl walking down the
street that's barely clothed and that's
pretty much what he's talking about
right so at a time people watching just
went to read to people about Jesus
you're not supposed to name the Freeport
Road
yeah I was researching yeah are you
talking about how they've all left the
know where this just seems like a bad
business model when you tell somebody
over and over and over again not to do
something it's like don't kids like yeah
his right shoulder think of a purple
elephant yeah what did you just think of
you know there's better ways to do this
you know
and that's the thing I'm not really I'm
not you know Christian I'm not really
religious whatever but when you have a
frank conversation with somebody about
sexuality or about pornography it
doesn't sound like that right it doesn't
sound like well you're possessed by
Satan and it doesn't sound like that
sounds like okay right just know that
these are the pitfalls of being porn
ruined and this is what it can do to
your marriage and this is what can do to
your relationship sector this is what it
can do to young minds who are like
sponges who don't understand what
intimacy is okay so I think I think
you're hitting it beyond on the head we
never have that discussion that we
always make it sound like it's crazy
religious people saying no porn or a
bunch of sex maniacs saying porn porn
porn but the truth is somewhere in the
middle which is yes you can what we've
all probably watched too much porn if I
could have some of that time back I
probably would have wrote more jokes I
could have been nicer right now you know
what I mean like we all could so but why
why are we afraid of having like an
honest conversation they want you to
think that it's something dirty so oh my
god it's dirty and I'm gonna feel bad
after I do it or watch it or whatever I
mean I've looked at porn I've looked at
part with my husband
I don't think it's made me a bad person
I'm not addicted to it it's not like I
look it up every night it hasn't ruined
our relationship we've been together 10
years we're having a child I think it's
like anything in life you try to learn
like you say you learned the pitfalls I
mean that's part of being a human being
and learning from your parents or
learning hopefully from your pastor that
maybe it's not that crazy about it but
you go look this can be bad this can be
bad I mean it's like smoking it's bad
for your health a could do this to you
it could give you lung cancer it can
make you die prematurely it can make you
look 10 years older than you are and you
know some people are probably still
gonna go smoke a cigarette and then
they're gonna go you know it's probably
not for me or I realize how to do it in
moderation or maybe I'm not gonna do it
at all but like where is it
that people you know the last time I
looked porn didn't kill anybody I mean
you know what I'm saying it didn't
actually physically murder anybody
people aren't dying from it so I'm like
you know well that's a funny thing he's
saying how what a detriment it is and as
a Christian this is your be your number
one right take that and figure it out
for myself
right lazy pastoring because when you
put just the Satan stamp of approval on
it without explaining you're anybody's
gonna want to go look at exactly and
yeah but is that part of the trick that
they're doing actually by saying it's so
bad they know that then you'll be
redeemed by the church so it's like this
is their little trick we're gonna tell
you about something we're gonna tell you
how much this is how much everybody
loves it it's awful come to us we'll say
you really are making me fielder I want
to go to the is their calendar or time
stamp somewhere cuz I'm going to say
something I have never said and never
thought I would say in a million years
we should take a page from the teachings
of George W Bush show and say with the
the splinter in the eye with the log in
the guy's mouth or whatever that was we
have to remember like these it's all
hypocrisy when you're saying all or
nothing do this and you're good don't do
this in you're bad I promise you Ellen's
cousin or whoever that guy does not do
that because he's human and that's what
makes us human we don't we alter and
make it's a big gray area so he just
needs to simmer down yeah by the way I
should say that I since I just fumbled
my way into the segment because I was so
shocked by it
that's a Florida pastor by the way and
he's starting something called a million
men and he wants a million men 1 million
men to swear off the porn so good all
right last segment here we go it has
been a summer of blockbuster flops from
White House down and Olympus has fallen
World War Z didn't do as well as people
thought oblivion a little bit before
that
now the Lone Ranger is tanking they're
saying it's gonna lose like 150 million
bucks all the big boys and that's what
summer's are all about
big popcorn flicks they're all crumbling
and losing money for the studios I think
there might be something culturally good
going on here that we're starting for
the first time could it be possible that
Americans are getting sick of the giant
machine that pumps out transformers
Michael Bay crap endlessly I hope so I I
think and I think it's the same for
women I don't see big transformer movies
with the Gobots and whatever and I don't
see rom-coms
a lot of nerds are not I prefer gobots
but I think they're both they're both
lazy writing they neither neither side
of the spectrum appeals to me and I I
hope you're right and and these guys you
know the Will Smith's and the Tom
Cruise's and all this stuff they're not
they're not gods they're not invincible
they're not you know they might and Brad
Pitt's gonna be turning 50 Wilson is 44
but still I mean he ain't well he's
always sort of been pegged as like well
with the young kid he can still act like
the 20-something and get away with it in
a movie yeah well actually after Earth
was the one that I forgot to mention and
that was one of the biggest bombs and I
think part of it is directly because of
people how people are now feeling about
his son yeah do you think that's part of
it that it's like you know most kids get
like you know a toy or a video game for
their birthday his son got a movie like
here take this movie do you think part
of this is like people are starting to
turn against the big stars a little bit
I think look I'm I'm a movie goer so I
go see all the big movies I still go see
independent movies and stuff too but you
know I think like with Johnny Depp
there's been a lot of stories Lone
Ranger has tanked it hasn't affected
Disney stock which I thought was very
interesting because they said a few
months ago that the investors actually
thought probably gonna be a tank because
people were not reviewing it well and
I'm thinking wow they're okay with a
hundred sixty million dollar loss
they've already like accepted that into
their
right so much but but when people are
talking about Johnny Depp as an actor
and probably these other guys it's like
a they're they're just kind of mailing
it in which has become like okay what
happened to the Johnny Depp of old that
was like the quirky guy but that had
some substance behind his really cool
characters now he's just flopping his
arms and doing the same sort of Pirates
of the Caribbean stick in the Lone
Ranger well it looks like it's just a
different costume like they had which
you know I think people are getting sick
oh and then be the rioting all we're
doing now is seeing remakes of past
movies or past TV shows and I'm thinking
to myself I mean the last great movie
that I really really really liked was
that was original was inception and I
was like what it was a fantastic movie
that you had to watch a couple times
thing you gotta think about all the way
to the very end and even then you're
having discussions and it was like oh my
god it was a it was an original movie
idea with great acting or great
storyline it made you think you had to
stay focused through the entire movie
instead of these like you know I don't
know how many Superman's are we doing
and how many transformers are we doing
I'm like people are getting sick about I
think people are like oh my god another
we ready first movie yeah I mean really
there's already ready to think there's
an app called run pee I don't know if
you're familiar but it basically tell
you we're in the movie you can go pee
and not miss anything this is just pee
gonna miss anything and I you know it to
be honest that's rude like I said it's
not really my kind of movie I did see
World War Z yeah that was great yeah I
thought it was great it was hey I am
Legend even he is cool whatever but I
gotta say as far as apocalyptic movies
are concerned this is the end the best
movie Marius because the writings great
the banter is funny the story I didn't
ever realize it was like a stupid zombie
movie until halfway through and that
proves the point though because that was
a smart well-written okay well it's not
on this list of massive budget because
there's no really big movie action stars
like these guys you know in it but it
big ensembles great the writings funny
yeah everything about it is this kind of
tongue-in-cheek but it was original this
money and maybe you know with stuff like
Breaking Bad Walking Dead maybe we are
getting smarter that's perfect your
cable channel your yeah whatever you do
that's that's private up to you but I
think you're on it with that about this
idea that there's so much good
television right now you know a to me in
between and if you want to get your
zombies you can watch Walking Dead and
it's great and Breaking Bad or what's
the other way what's the other one
what's the one on Netflix with Kevin
Spacey you were like if he didn't I
wouldn't know what a whip was so I have
to you know you're talking about how
swim yeah yeah so alright on your porn
channel today I'm finding this rather
inspiring we all seem to be agreeing
that maybe Americans are ready for some
smarter could it possibly be and you
know what the one thing over anything in
any situation if you talk with your
checkbook or you talk with your wallet
people will have to listen up and you
win when they said oh you know maybe for
Independence Day we're not gonna hire
Will Smith because you know what he's
diminishing in how fans like him and
really can we afford that paycheck
finally a move a movie production
company that's going you know maybe it's
not worth it mark finally in case you're
this ain't no yes so Independence Day to
is not going to have Will Smith tonight
in case which is great I mean why not
have somebody new yeah you know I mean
again it's another you know sequel to
another movie which is driving me crazy
can't we just right I mean where are the
writers in Hollywood
really the write something original like
most Japanese right exactly I mean with
the upstart of great cable television
shows but you know all of the regular
you know free TV you know dramas really
in comedies of you know they've all
disappeared over the years there's no
more friends there's no more in shows
like that and it's like right
like oh we have nothing else to work on
everything's reality and I'm like well
if you're writing really good quality
stuff filling prophecy we can still turn
the ship around you know I don't hold it
against the big stars I mean get your
paycheck man putting it but any of them
yeah but on the other hand it's like
well hubris like you're not maybe you're
not you're not worth that anymore and in
this article actually that you sent us
Tom Cruise has were gone like a movie
that he agreed to so he could go back
and make another Mission Impossible
movie because he knows that's that's the
cash cow that's the moneymaker right I
actually thought Oblivion was pretty
decent but by the time we blinked and my
husband came back from a trip it was it
was not in the movie theater anymore
well final point of this do you think
that's actually part of the problem that
everyone gets so hyped for these big
movies that if you don't see it in the
first two days it's still there it's
still there but it's like oh I already
missed the exciting you're about it when
people are like oh it sucks and then
people go yeah you know I don't to spend
my twenty dollars at the movie theater
then I'll go see something else that
I've heard is good you're a real movie
buff you give it to them that first
weekend because that's all that anybody
gives a [ __ ] about and you know hi you
don't really want to help you're gonna
get it on Netflix oh you're gonna get it
on DVD or you're gonna watch it on HBO
anyway so a lot of times people I've
asked my friends Mike hey have you gone
see double blind then in the movie
theater no I just wait for it to come
out
I'll watch at home it's like you know
unless it's such a great movie that you
have to see it on the big screen but all
the bells and whistles he's like no I'll
just wait for it to come out on DVD yeah
like really you never used to be that
way
you know what I in these here parts we
appreciate you watching it on YouTube so
there's a subscribe button right down
there I want to thank my guest Lee Anne
to Eden and Gina grad there on the
Twitter and you can see their little
Twitter handles right there as well and
now you can go back to your red tube as
we and recommend it or you can go into
your internet browser thing and block
all that stuff as the man from the
man horn and Bing doesn't want you to do
okay we'll do this again next week